Uno, dos, tres, go!
Reunion day with our
Charlie's Angels.
What's the guy's name?
Charlie.
(Laughter)
You're invited to the 3-part
Real Housewives
of Miami Reunion!
- Cheers, guys.
- (all) Cheers.
Wow, that was strong.
(Laughter)
Let's turn this up!
Yay!
Wooo!
Who here do you think
has the most sex?
(Laughter)
I've always had sex,
like, four times a night.
Four times a night?
Your poor vagina.
Jacqueline from New York
City said, "Marcus is closer
in age to your son Scotty
Junior than to you."
He wears a size fifteen
shoe so I think he's okay.
Oh s***.
Martina's diagnosis has
radically changed.
We are fighting two cancers.
Like one was not enough.
I've heard Lenny.
He's been a cheater
for a long time.
Like I know models
that he'd cheat with.
A lot of people commented,
"The girls all have a
real sisterhood."
You haven't given
me a "Sorry."
You haven't given me
a “Thank you."
You know what?
You're not gonna
castrate me,
just like you
castrated Russell!
Who is this from?
Read the letter.
Dear Adriana, I'm writing to
tell you, I'm being abused.
The culprit of this
abuse is Marysol.
And you said, "I'm
a star! I'm a star!"
If you believe that,
you would have not
let Lenny do all the
things he's done to you.
What?
Yes.
Why would you try
to take me down?
I never wanted anything to
do with your ex-boyfriend!
I regret it!
You're the narcissist
that has no feelings!
And you don’t
even apologize.
I don't apologize
to the devil.
Show of hands, does
Larsa hit below the belt?
And no one's talking to you.
Shh! Put a muzzle on, girl.
I can't stand a man that
talks s*** about a woman.
- Anthony's a b****!
- And Anthony said that!
- Anthony is a b****!
- So, hold on!
Okay! Okay!
You slept with
- every person.
- I said I heard!
I said I heard!
Cuckoo!
We're all talking at
the same  f****** time!
Oh!
Ooh! Kiki’s d***
boobie slipped.